علامه وزاره دفاع روسيه مقتل اكثر من
سبعين عسكريا اوكانيا فيها هجمات للقوه
الروسيه على محور جنوب دونيتس باقليم
دمباز وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور
كوناشينغوف ان قوه المدفعيه والصواريخ
الروسيه دمرت مقر قياده للقوات قوات
الاحتياط الاوكرانيه في مدينه اكرامتوس
في محوري
المدفعيه الروسيه هزيمه بوحدات لواء
الدفاع الاقليميه الحادي عشر في بلده
تروسكوي في جمهوريه الشعبيه
بلغت خسائر العدو خلال يوم واحد في هذا
المحور اكثر من اربعين عسكريا وتم تدمير
مركبات
وشاحنتين عسكريتين وفي اتجاه الدنيا وفي
سياقه هجماتنا الناجحه هل حقت قواتنا
الهزيمه بوحدات لواء الهجوم الجويه
التاسعه والسبعين التابع للقوات
الاوكرانيه وتم القضاء على 60 عسكريا
وتدمر عشر مركبات اما في الاتجاه الجنوبي
من دونيات فقد قتل اكثر من 70 عسكريا
اوكرانيا وتم تدميره اليات عسكريه نتيجه
ضربت ناريه معقده نفذتها قواتنا